dear mr. Donald Trump I'd like to take a
minute to introduce you to my father but
will of Monza as you so eloquently put
it he is one of the many that Mexico
sends to this country 37 years ago
Mexico sent my father to the United
States or North Bay as we call it it is
no secret that he came here undocumented
unauthorized or illegal as you call it
he worked his ass off in the field
traveling from state to state to find
work he helped provide for his parents
and nine siblings back home and when I
was born he no longer held the title of
just his son's brother provider and
migrant worker he finally earned the
title of father
so ole doesn't have what you call a
formal education he left high school
early on to work and contribute to the
household financially but that doesn't
mean anything when I was young I would
come home where my dad never hesitated
to help me with my homework he instilled
in me the importance of education and a
degree even though he didn't have one my
dad has worked five to six days a week
since I was a child and I've never heard
him complain about it one time he
doesn't drink he doesn't use drugs he is
certainly not a criminal rapist or drug
trafficker as your speech suggested mr.
Trump in your speech you claim that
Mexico doesn't send the u.s. their best
but I beg to differ if my dad has any
representation of the type of people
Mexico sends there's no doubt in my mind
this country is getting the best the
problem is that you and I have a
different definition of the best I stand
here now with a master's degree and a
rewarding career you know what that
means absolutely nothing my entire life
the only thing I ever wanted was to make
my dad proud I wanted to be sure he knew
that his sacrifices would never be taken
for granted we are not rich in wealth
sir but we are rich in what matters
knowledge culture and faith we come from
humble beginnings and every year we are
reminded of that when we travel to
Mexico to visit our beautiful family to
us that is what matters the best to me
are those that work hard and still
remain humble that is exactly what my
father embodies that is exactly what the
other millions of Mexicans embodies
perhaps you should get to know more
people like my dad there are millions
just like him then you'd see for years
and instead of fashion Mexico you think
Mexico or sending us to their best
when Mexico sends his people